i
[Música]
hola soy sam' y les voy a contar una
historia había una vez una persona que
toda su vida o por lo menos desde que
tenía memoria se había esforzado por
alcanzar el éxito de una manera
constante
poco a poco pudo adquirir su primera
casa su primer auto y logro conocer a
alguien con quien por fin entabló una
relación formal después de tantas
relaciones fallidas sin embargo pese a
la cantidad de esfuerzo y éxito obtenido
aún sentía que algo faltaba en su vida
pero que había pasado si siguió las
fórmulas de la felicidad y el éxito se
preparó se capacitó tuvo la actitud y
luchó contra su temperamento y genética
se adapta a las circunstancias a los
salarios bajos aprendió que había
pensamientos diferentes y hasta logró
cambiar sus hábitos de lectura y de vida
te suena familiar
porque muchos nos hemos sentido
culpables por no ser felices a pesar de
tenerlo todo o estar mucho mejor que
otros por eso hoy les voy a explicar
cómo ser un depresivo exitoso y no morir
en el intento
y por exitoso no me refiero a tener el
auto del año o una cuenta bancaria con
grandes ceros porque claro a mí me
encantaría llorar en un yate y no en mi
bolso viejo y oxidado
muchas veces nos han dicho y nos hemos
creído que para ser felices primero se
debe de ser exitoso así que me di a la
tarea de investigar las fórmulas de la
felicidad y el éxito según los expertos
la que más me llamó la atención fue
creada en 1999 por el doctor martín
seligman esta fórmula habla sobre la
psicología positiva y explica qué efe es
igual a r
b les explico efe es la felicidad
duradera lo que te hace feliz ere que
ocupa un 50% es el rango base de las
características con las que nacemos nada
más y nada menos que nuestra genética sé
que tiene un 10% son las circunstancias
que vivimos día a día mientras que el
último 40% representa nuestra voluntad
y si es modificable así que tienen razón
aquellas personas que nos han dicho que
depende de nosotros desde pequeños nos
enseñan a través de las normas sociales
que es lo correcto y lo incorrecto qué
es lo bueno o lo malo lo normal y en
este aprendizaje que llevamos en la vida
buscamos la aceptación la atención el
cariño la autorrealización y si el éxito
ya saben nos comportamos de tal manera
que encajemos ante la presión social
pero si nos salimos de lo normal que
somos y no la respuesta no es que somos
raros es muy sencilla
somos extraordinarios
considero que no es malo demostrar
nuestras emociones solo hay que aprender
a regularlas y no dejar que nos
sobrepasen entender que las dificultades
aparecen una vez que las reprimimos pero
qué pasa si no somos capaces de regular
estas emociones fácil nos enfermamos las
plaquetas se bajan el insomnio se hace
presente y andamos por la vida con cara
de perro esto le da puerta abierta a la
presencia de enfermedades mentales las
que te hacen generar un bucle de
pensamientos depresivos que hacen que
nos envolvemos en nuestra propia víctima
es porque ha sido más fácil
martirizarnos que aceptarnos y la verdad
es que las enfermedades como es el caso
de la depresión no distinguen de raza
sexo o clase social bla bla bla
la depresión es como las cucarachas
hasta en las casas de las mejores
familias hay
existen tantos tipos de depresiones de
ahí se deriva la dificultad de un
diagnóstico y también el tipo de
tratamiento y lo vimos en la vida diaria
él sí puede estar deprimido porque no
tiene dinero porque su esposa lo dejo
porque su hijo se murió pero aquella
persona no porque todo lo tienen tiene
una casa hermosa una familia de ejemplo
ella es speaker ente de c's entonces si
está deprimida está loca y no se valora
de acuerdo con la organización mundial
de la salud se estima que la depresión
es la cuarta enfermedad que más
incapacidad provoca en el mundo y que es
una enfermedad frecuente que afecta a
más de 300 millones de personas
la depresión difiere de las variaciones
habituales del estado de ánimo y de la
respuesta emocional ante los problemas
de la vida cotidiana sin embargo puede
convertirse en un problema de salud
serio siendo de larga duración de
intensidad moderada
causando un gran sufrimiento y alterando
las actividades laborales escolares y
familiares
en el peor de los casos puede llevar al
suicidio
en este sentido la oms también indica
que al año más de 800 mil personas se
quitan la vida y que es la segunda causa
de muerte en personas de entre 15 y 29
años
en nuestro país en el 2001 se
registraron tres mil 784 suicidios
mientras que para el 2010 el número
ascendió a más de 5000
de acuerdo con la cruz roja se estima
que para el 2020 las víctimas podrían
ascender a 1.5 millones de manera global
bueno imagínense que van dispuestos a
pasar un fin de semana increíble a uno
de los paraísos naturales que tenemos en
nuestro país
y al llegar al lugar todos los
habitantes se han quitado la vida
haciendo una comparativa con el número
actual de habitantes en quintana roo
es el número de suicidios que tendremos
para el 2020
1.5 millones de manera mundial
cuando tenía 14 años
e intenté quitarme la vida
es por eso que quiero compartir con
ustedes algunos momentos decisivos que
me han llevado a donde hoy estoy
a querer ayudar a personas como tú como
tú o como yo
depresivos exitosos para que no mueran
en el intento
en una cena navideña durante la
repartición de regalos mientras todos
reíamos medio los acercó a mí y me
preguntó pulguita qué hubiese pasado si
te hubieses logrado quitar la vida
en ese momento me enoje pero muy en el
fondo sabía que tenía razón
un 12 de enero de hace 10 años quise
tomar la mejor decisión para todos
yo no me valoraba y consideraba que no
encajaba en ningún lugar
después de varios intentos ese día iba a
ser el definitivo
sin embargo
un niño de año y medio al cual amo con
todo mi corazón
[Música]
se acercó a mí
y con su poca habilidad para hablar me
dijo hermanita feliz cumpleaños
eso me dio la fuerza que necesitaba
yo quería estar ahí y ver crecer a mi
hermano
porque el a su poca edad me hizo sentir
que pertenecía a algo y que le importaba
a alguien
crecer después de eso no fue nada fácil
pero la verdad había un gran motivo para
seguir
la verdad ya le había agarrado gusto a
vivir
a los 16 nos mudamos a querétaro y un
viernes en la mañana mi rodilla empezó a
doler para el lunes ya no podía caminar
un mes después había perdido la
movilidad completa de esa pierna
situación que me llevó al quirófano
nunca valore tanto mis extremidades como
cuando el médico me indicó que tenía
artritis juvenil pase por más citas
médicas que con pretendientes
a los 21 en otra revisión
el médico me indicó que tenía que
extirpar un tumor
con la expectativa lo desconocido y con
antecedentes de una abuela que había
fallecido de cáncer de mama
en ese momento me dije no no se vale no
se vale porque yo ya quiero vivir
volví a entrar en una depresión muy muy
fuerte y hablando con un desconocido me
motivó a vivir como realmente yo quería
vivir y entender que no había nada que
me entrenara
así que me puse tres metas graduarme
pagar una deuda y viajar a california
sin tener noción de cómo hacerlo
faltando un mes y medio para finalizar
el año y sabiendo que tenía el tiempo
contado no sólo logré cumplir estas
metas sino también tener el deseo de
impactar en los demás pero como podría
hacerlo leí un artículo escrito por
beatriz lópez donde mencionaba que desde
la antigüedad ya se conocían las
propiedades terapéuticas del arte y sus
beneficios en las generalidades del ser
humano entonces se me ocurrió que ésta
sería una buena opción
y afrontar la batalla de la aceptación y
lidiar con la realidad como un regulador
de nuestras emociones
yo estuve ahí en esa depresión que te
asfixia y el arte y la fotografía me han
salvado la vida
actualmente junto con unos amigos estoy
trabajando en la creación de un club de
apoyo que consiste en lo siguiente le
pusimos por nombre sobre lo que
significa el sol al final del camino
dentro del club realizaremos diferentes
actividades de expresión
en su abuelo manejaremos pláticas
talleres actividades sociales
ambientales y culturales con el objetivo
de crear lazos e involucramiento entre
los participantes a través de las
experiencias que de ella emana
se busca aprender a regular sin sentirse
mal y sin miedo al fracaso drenando todo
a través del arte
cuando una serpiente te muerde el veneno
te puede matar pero ese mismo veneno se
puede utilizar como antídoto lo mismo
sucede con nuestras emociones y hay que
entender que en esta vida hay muchas
cosas que van a doler hay cosas malas
situaciones que lastiman o momentos
difíciles pero solo son esos momentos
es ahí donde debemos tomar nuestras
emociones con inteligencia utilizando
las como impulsos
yo lo entendí y estos tatuajes me
recuerdan diariamente lo fuerte que soy
porque estas marcas solo cubren las
verdaderas cicatrices del alma
vale la pena aceptar que algo no está
bien en nuestras vidas y que necesitamos
buscar ayuda pero lo más lo más
importante es querer salir de la
depresión para no morir en el intento
hay que entender que nuestra vida está
en riesgo y que el único que puede
salvarnos es uno mismo
gracias
[Aplausos]